ding has chosen to start with the black
pieces and here we go what are we seeing
on the board okay it's very early will
we now see the queen's gambit will we
see the nimzo indian okay we do see the
queen's gambit declined for i think a
third fourth time in this match already
from the ding uh from dingler inside and
the uh rygozian variation white's queen
jumped out to give a check this is still
very well-known stuff white's lost a bit
of time with his queen but uh there are
reasons for that black's rook meanwhile
developing black ready to throw pawns
forward in the center of the board if
possible and uh yeah just early days
nice development from both sides and uh
just a reminder about uh regulations for
the blitz tiebreaks they play two games
one with the white pieces each and if
they are still tied we will head to
armageddon where we definitely will
decide a winner and of course time
control in blitz david yeah the time
control is five minutes per player on
the clock but they do gain three seconds
after every move so pretty much three
times quicker than the rapid chest that
we've been seeing so far in the event
and uh yeah the players they've been
playing very quickly up to this point
that is good always the hardest part is
switching from rapid to blitz just that
mentality that's just that speed that uh
decisiveness and uh simon what do you
think of the position yeah well i think
first of all it's a much quicker switch
to this time limit than we saw on the
previous uh playoff where
i think prague was you know i think
against the niche where he had a
brilliant result being a niche but that
he was moving a lot slower so that's a
positive positive sign uh i mean
generally uh these the i like these
structures for white because i like
having an extra pawn in the center and
that's just you know one very basic
thing i can say about this i prefer to
be white but black's very solid and
black can get his bishop on a lovely
diagonal
on the next move so it's all pretty
normal at the moment i feel um i'm sure
ding has prepared this position but uh
yeah i'd still rather take white
slightly at the moment yeah you've
jinxed him though simon just as you say
he was playing quicker he's now stopped
for one minute on this i'm so good at
jinxing people
if you ever want to lose a tournament
just let me say you're going to win it
and you'll be fine i mean like yeah got
to stop it
well we just saw some action in the
center and
now pragan ananda has taken control and
it's all about whether ding can start
destabilizing those pawns in the middle
yeah first of all it's time for prague
to castle get that white king to safety
uh you do have the pawns in the center
but they will get undermined in a moment
ding is gonna start challenging those
two white central pawns
so before things open up why not get
your king to safety
and uh okay he doesn't do this he pushes
even more pawns he's trying to stop
black from breaking out on this left
side of the board he's partly gaining
space partly to stop the breakout and
ding very mysterious move but there is a
specific reason first he protects his
light square bishop that rook move
notice how the black rook is on the same
line as the white queen if things open
up that might be a factor later ding
moving so quickly i mean he's up on time
i mean this is uh you know he's really
playing ala tempo here
and keeping the speed up which is going
to put some pressure on prague if he
starts to freeze a little bit saying
that this is this is a key moment now
now black trying to break through and
white has a tricky decision to make here
yeah do you take this pawn if so which
way do you take this pawn do you leave
this pawn
um yeah simon just threw ivanka there's
three four choices i kind of don't like
prague's b4 it kind of seems like he's
just given a ding a target actually um
to to play against i think ding's rook
v8 seemed very very clever um okay so
he's now trying to make some exchanges
maybe he will push on with a b pawn okay
no he's hitting that rook yeah so uh you
mentioned that clever move that black
had of just swinging the rook across i
was going to say the position's about to
open up and that black rook is going to
look great opposite the white queen but
no maybe a clever move there from prague
hitting that rook
maybe forcing it to move again
will we see another set of trades of
pawns the position is really blowing
open now
and uh ding has slightly slowed down
still much much ahead on the clock
though
yeah a really really tense position
because uh you know white has signaled
their intentions you know once the pawns
get eliminated the rooks will come to
the open lines the queen will also start
occupying long diagonals
and i'm not entirely sure who is
actually better here it does feel like
pragananda still has a slight pull
especially with his time control but he
is
down on the clock yeah to be honest just
from my experience playing blitz it's a
lot of responsibility having more space
your pawns further forward and here
that's the case for pragnanda if you
look at white's pawn in the center of
the board that is a target for black's
pieces when you're playing blitz you
don't want to be stuck defending those
pawns worrying it will drop off the
whole time so there's reasons for dean
to be happy as well i mean while ding's
rook did move out of the eye line of
that white bishop in the centre of the
board and decision time for prague how
does he improve the white rooks first he
trades upon and white's queen is
actually attacking the bishop up there
the black slight square bishop then
again if the white queen moves then
white light square bishop falls to the
black queen so uh yeah a bit of tension
there
is ding gonna blink and move his bishop
or is he just gonna ignore it and take
back this black port uh this white pawn
and uh he captures the pawn and now the
question is there's a lot of captures
now there's the queen takes the bishop
there's bishop takes knight there's so
many on the board
um
which one to go for i mean it's all on
the pieces isn't it because it is a
symmetrical structure now so uh but that
doesn't mean it's equal here because
there's pieces everywhere and there's
pieces everywhere being attacked so they
gotta remain sharp here one little
mistake and something could easily uh
drop off time situation okay still a bit
wearing for prague i mean he's he's gone
too he's done half of his time uh and
ding has four minutes so that that's
again
will be important later on
okay first the bishop steps back
attacking black's rook black's rook now
might step two squares back
that black light square bishop is also
under fire so double attack black's rook
had to protect his bishop there we go
and uh yeah still very loose white
pieces white's minor pieces the knight
and two bishops
wow feel uncomfortable there but prague
gets greedy brave move
so could there be lots of
simplifications now of black okay black
doesn't take the pawn in the middle he
he switches his queen over and uh
um i'm kind of yeah i don't know i mean
it looks like black's pieces are working
so well together now all the black's
pieces look beautiful and um your pawn
up though is white yeah but
temporarily
pins all over the board and uh okay
white defends the pawn in the middle but
i'm just looking at the queen and the
bishop how they're lined up on the same
line
and then
the white queen of bishop right sorry
yeah the white queen and bishop yeah and
also the black queen and bishop
beautiful diagonal for them
here's a pawn though it is a pawn and we
saw prague win a game earlier on today
where he he won a pawn and he held on to
that pawn even though it looked like
ding had loads of pressure throughout
that pawn won the game so that extra
pawn you know it's nice to have and his
one win yesterday prague that was
because he had an extra pawn and guided
it to victory so he's two wins so far
against have both been from getting
greedy and just holding on to the extra
material
and uh there we go white's bishop was
under fire retreats back to the center
black's knight now putting some pressure
on bishops i don't think ideally you
want to take off this black knight with
one of your bishops
if black's two bishops get active then
black will be in control despite the
pawn deficit
so white ideally wants to keep his
bishops nice and safe and there we go
the bishop steps away from potential
capture
how can black improve maybe the black
rooks now will start lining up in the
middle of the board
can you go crazy and play the f pawn up
two squares
well i'm thinking okay it's a bit too
much maybe but you know at some point
that that could really
it's still there it's still there i mean
it could bring things to life like now
it's even stronger because uh
you you you certainly hit a lot of
people and it's on the board
simon the fortune teller i'm always a
dutch player on i you know once the
dutch player i'm always going to push
that f pawn two squares if i can
and with the time situation i think this
is a very good practical move going for
maximum complications when your opponent
prag is only one and a half minutes left
ticking down quickly yeah we saw the
evaluation bus swing objectively this
move might be a bit dodgy it does open
up the black king but simon's right it's
the practical value uh making your
opponent guess making them navigate this
kind of tricky muddy waters and the
white queen lining itself up on the same
diagonal as the black king but
what's happening here maybe black now
can go and attack the white queen nice
intermediate move there from ding before
the white bishop is captured white's
actually a piece up first ding went to
attack this white queen where to move
her that's the question i guess i'd love
to get rid of that bishop um and this is
a brilliant what a brilliant move look
at this stockfish confirms that was the
best move and ding instantly reacted
look at ding devastated wow
how did he find that prague within
seconds that's a beautiful move your
queen was attacked but you kind of do a
bit of a crisscross you counter attack
against the black queen in the corner of
the board if black gets greedy now and
grabs the white queen black's queen
falls off as well white is going to be a
pawn up in a simplified position
what a move by prague incredible move
right important to find that
instantaneously with this crisscross
situation and that's put him in a
driving seat now if he can just hold on
to the time and yeah like you said david
it's ding's face it just dropped
immediately and he's done that a couple
of times today we have to show this
because it looked like white was in big
trouble this queen was attacked and next
move wherever she moves suddenly the
other black bishop would jump out taking
the white bishop and look at these two
pieces dominant the white knight now
about to fall off but pregnant he had
seen even further into the future ding
had missed that bishop takes pawn does
this crisscross movement and uh here we
go the queens may be about to leave the
board if black does play bishop takes
queen then white is simply doing great
uh yeah white will end up with at least
an extra pawn and here we go ding
couldn't touch the queens he didn't take
the queens but now in the current
position we see white simply one extra
pawn black has an isolated pawn in the
middle also the black king very weak on
this diagonal what a chance for prague
this is a great chance for prague i mean
this could be a dream coming true in
this game obviously there's another game
after this but he's a porn up with a
better king and look at the a pawn
shooting up the board again simon he won
the earlier game with his a pawn and now
he's winning again with his a pawn
i mean just mirroring all of these uh
all of these games and
i mean ding i can't blame him at all
that tactic was so hard to see but
prague found it i mean ding's play i
thought he was playing very well i just
uh you know not as well as prague
i have to say you know
prague has been playing in a really calm
way you know he's allowed the rook onto
the second row
he's calculated everything that the game
will be won because of the a pawn and
okay dangerous threat on the board for
prague the black queen is threatening to
come down and capture the f2 pawn with a
deadly check yeah black's queen and the
black rook on the second rank they're
teaming up first though prec and
flicking a greedy move another pawn
capture paul grab and then why not go on
the defensive you're now two pawns up
with white and the white knight is about
to start jumping in towards the black
king this is surely over isn't it
totally must be winning yeah i mean he's
got 45 seconds but
i mean this will mean ding needs to
bounce back in the next game
and prague's been so good today
so good just reminded me of magnus at
his best the way he's playing today
uh in these games
i mean just almost speechless with
running out of superlatives for him
running out of praise for prague because
he's just so good right now and uh he's
just with this last defensive move
guarding the pawn near the white king
he's just ensured there's no more risk
and look at the light squares around the
black king there's so many open light
squares the white knight is about to
start jumping in that might be deadly
first the black bishop is lining up
against the white king but that is not a
real scary threat white's king can
happily hide on a light square in the
corner
and yes you can gain back one pawn with
ding but it takes too long
not only does white have this extra a
pawn that queen and knight combo that's
incoming from prague that's gonna decide
this game at least black does have a
blockade of the a pawn you know at least
and the queen the queen and knight look
like they should win the game but
you know you might need to get another
piece into the attack to to finish it
off somehow there's still some chances
to think if ding can draw this it'd be
you know a amazing result for him and
now both players around the 40-second
mark which means the nerves could start
jangling and ding offers a trade of
queens question to trade or not to trade
that is the question
no trade no don't trade because the
black king is totally unsafe
keep queens on let the queen and knight
together do some damage
under 20 seconds i mean something like
queen over two squares keeping the light
squares seems very natural
i don't like that decision that's safety
first but now the margin for error is
diminished it's lower if you lose one of
your two extra pawns with white
ding might draw this game and it's under
five seconds
prague must make a move okay so he
offers a trade of rooks and uh one point
is gonna drop off yeah that's really
clever now the black bishop is attacked
and actually um white was covering his
back rank so now he can keep his extra
pawn the white rook is very active
this is really clever from prague i
don't like the queen trade but still
he's in he's in charge he should still
win
yeah white king is coming as well
yeah give a check with the white knight
bring your white king towards the center
still looks very good doesn't it i mean
the white knight is a very powerful
piece in the center of the board here
even if the knight gets swapped for the
bishop it's a very tricky ending maybe
it's losing ending black's rook is so
bad it's so bad and white is so well
centralized in this position it still
must be prague who who's going to win
this game
with 15 seconds left on the board
against 33. i feel like prague is a bit
mean you know he gives ding a little bit
of hope and then plays this opening game
perfectly and says nope it was lost all
along yeah that white king actually has
a clear path towards the black pawns now
you can walk in on the light squares at
some point first black is trying to
cover the fifth rank white king maybe
shouldn't rush towards those black pawns
first a check a really annoying check
and okay he's just repeating the
position gaining a few seconds they do
gain three seconds after every move
so uh oh
seconds
low on the clock that's the only thing
that can really stop him it is a winning
position it's just the clock this is a
lovely tactic because i think now the a
pawn might come up the board and black's
possibly gonna have to sacrifice his
bishop for that pawn simplifying things
to prague even more i mean can you push
the pawn now or can you get your rook
behind the pawn we saw prague do this
before
and that white pawn will cost black his
bishop most likely uh okay the black can
slide behind yeah it's not so easy maybe
isn't it i mean like now that pawn is
gone okay it's all about the king side
pawns here right
prague just trying to i mean he's giving
up his pawn he's leaving it now he's
just trying to get active but i don't
know now i mean that that pawn was such
a trump you know this this i think now
has got better drawing chances yes the
black king is in a lot of trouble here
but if you can just
hold it off drawing chances yeah and now
the bishop rejoins the action
i mean it still feels so good but maybe
he's let it go maybe he's let it slip
now the bishop defends this key pawn on
the g7 square
prague's shaking his head
yeah maybe he's blown it i think he
tried to be a bit too clever i was
praising him i thought it was winning as
well but ding found a genius defense to
get rid of that white a pawn now two
seconds two versus two on the same side
oh practice playing with fire on the
clock
yeah
and how is he going to win
those black pawns are defended by their
bishop yeah look at the white king
what's you what weird square free not
necessarily stupid okay he's going for a
little sacrifice
but i think it's going to work though i
mean this is a this this pawn is going
to be exchanged and the rook is going to
just grab
the g pawn and then it's just a matter
of time before the rook pawn falls off
ding there he breathed out massively
he's so relieved and there we go it's a
draw a knight alone will not check mate
on the brink but not enough